how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU today we have some really exciting
and very interesting news about one of
the Marvel shows coming to Disney Plus
Marvel Studios is what if Marvel Studios
is what if is definitely going to be one
of the more interesting shows coming to
Disney Plus and really it's because the
whole point of the show is to change our
idea and perspective of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as we know it now
obviously it won't be for good or have
any main effect on the actual Marvel
Cinematic Universe timeline but it'll
explore what the universe could have
been if one simple act was changed
somewhere along the timeline and today
we have two and quite possibly three
plot details for three episodes of
Marvel Studios as what if coming to
Disney Plus there aren't really any
spoilers here but we are going to talk
about the scenarios that they are going
to change for example one episode could
talk about what if Tony Stark never
snapped but Steve Rogers actually
snapped what would happen so we'll go
over to confirm scenarios and another
scenario that is basically confirmed
just not official yet but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all things
relating to the MCU and so you can enter
my giveaway this week we're giving away
a Captain America Avengers in-game Funko
pop all you have to do to enter is be
subscribed like the video and leave a
comment about the video down below a
winner will be announced on Monday so
the first episode scenario of Marvel
Studios is what if that we're going to
talk about isn't exactly the first
episode but is an episode that is
believed to be coming and there is a lot
of proof behind it and the scenario is
actually quite interesting in the
scenario is what if Peter Parker
spider-man became Hawkeye now this is
pretty much confirmed and the reason
that I say that is because an old video
has resurfaced online from San Diego
comic-con from variety now a variety of
course was at San Diego comic-con and
varieties Matt Donnally was actually
attending the Hall H panel for Marvel at
SDCC and after the panel they
interviewed him and asked him what he
saw and he said that he saw spider-man
as Hawkeye all of the heroes you know
and love sort of recast in different
roles I know it's sort of hard to to
imagine but they showed images of Tom
Holland
Hawkeye they showed Peggy Peggy Hayley
Atwell as Captain America so as you just
heard he saw an actual photo of Peter
Parker as Hawkeye and not just one photo
but multiple photos he says I know it's
sort of hard to imagine but they showed
images of Tom Holland as Hawkeye now the
reason I say this is not 100% confirmed
to be an episode is because we haven't
seen this yet we have gotten a little
teaser of what the Marvel what-if series
is going to be and we have even seen
some leaked photos as well which we'll
talk about in a bit but out of all of
these things that we've seen from this
new animated series come in to Disney
Plus we have not seen Peter Parker as
Hawkeye so this could have simply just
been concept art used that sdcc just to
show the fans what they're going to see
with Marvel's what if or since there
were multiple images shown it could be
an episode of what if now this certainly
would be a very interesting episode
because this would really affect the MCU
for starters we wouldn't have a
spider-man but maybe he still has some
of his supernatural abilities maybe he
just doesn't build his web-slinger's
either way he would go on to become
Hawkeye and he would be a very different
character in the MCU as the episode
would no doubt go on to explore we would
probably find that Peter Parker would
not have nearly the same relationship
with Tony Stark that he did as
spider-man the whole reason that Tony
Stark found Peter Parker was because he
saw some leaked videos of spider-man
online well without those leaked videos
there's no spider-man there for Tony
Stark cannot find Peter Parker at least
not that way he'd have to find him some
other way and perhaps it's even Hawkeye
Clint Barton himself that finds him he
could find him train him and then give
him the mantle of Hawkeye when he's on
house arrest and he really quits the
Avengers after Civil War
perhaps Nick Fury locates somebody with
special abilities and sends Hawkeye to
go get him now as you can see this one
simple change would drastically change
the events of the MCU again we wouldn't
have spider-man but Peter Parker was a
very big driving force to Tony Stark in
Avengers in game in fact it was the
photo of Peter Parker that really
convinced Tony to explore time-travel
and give it a go and then of course if
we didn't have a relationship with Peter
Parker and Tony Stark we wouldn't have
that final scene with Tony Stark and
Peter Parker right before he dies which
of course choked everybody up so this
will certainly be an interesting episode
and it seems like Marvel Studios is
pretty fond of the character swap idea
as I mentioned there are three other
episodes that are absolutely confirmed
to be coming to Marvel's what-if and one
of them is going to be about what if
Peggy Carter took the Super Soldier
serum and not Steve Rogers now we
actually have more photos about this
specific episode than we have of any
other photos thanks to Disney Plus and
the implications of this change actually
really affect what could have happened
thanks to these photos we know that
Peggy Carter goes through the same
procedure that Steve Rogers went through
she gets the Super Soldier Serum and she
becomes a super soldier but she's not
from America so she doesn't go on to
become Captain America instead it's a
captain in Britain and no not the same
Captain Britain from the comics but a
female version of Captain America that
is Captain Britain so she gets the serum
becomes a female version of Captain
America and she is definitely a super
soldier as we have seen footage of her
basically flipping a car over with her
shield now this scenario is awesome as
it is but what else happens is truly
awesome as well
in this scenario Steve Rogers never gets
the serum so one would think that he
wouldn't be allowed to join the army
because he wasn't allowed to before
however according to this what if
episode there was different value found
in Steve Rogers and he sort of becomes a
new in the first Ironman we find out
that if Steve Rogers was never given the
Super Soldier Serum and never became
Captain America he would still join the
army and Howard Stark the father of Tony
Stark would end up creating an Iron Man
like type of suit for him and Steve
Rogers would be the first person to
operate this new Iron Man tech and as
you can see here he would still have a
relationship with Peggy Carter after ala
was Peggy in the beginning who was
rooting for Steve Rogers but in these
photos we can see him pop out of the
Iron Man armor and we even see him
taking off into the sky with Peggy
Carter on his back and you can see them
flying through the air together in this
photo as well so as you can see even if
Steve Rogers never became Captain
America never got the Super Soldier
Serum he would still be a great soldier
who would want to serve his country
and he would do so and essentially go on
to become the first Ironman and it looks
like he would still end up with Peggy
Carter as well certainly an interesting
scenario to think about and something
that I definitely look forward to seeing
on Marvel's what if and then in another
episode with another character swap we
have what if T'Challa was star-lord not
much is really known about this episode
and it is kind of hard to guess but in
these photos that we have we do see
T'Challa as star-lord he has the same
suit the same mask and in this scene
that we have here he's still retrieving
the ore but which contains the power
stone so what probably happens here is
that yondu and crag lion instead of
going and picking up Peter quill they
actually go to Wakanda and they end up
picking up two cella
now this would actually drastically
alter the MCU in many different ways the
obvious one would be that eventually
what Conda would not have a king to
chaco would still most likely go on to
be killed during the United Nations
meeting however his son would not be
there and he doesn't have another son
this means that either mbaku or kill
monger would eventually come and become
king of Wakanda now if this did happen
that means there is no black panther in
civil war and if there is no black
panther in civil war that means that
Bucky would never go to Wakanda and when
Bucky was in Wakanda they wiped away his
brainwashing they made it to where he
can't be turned back into the Winter
Soldier
so if T'Challa became star-lord the
Winter Soldier would still be lurking
inside of him it could be reactivated
and if there was no black panther and
civil war then the Avengers could not
use Wakanda and infinity war not to
mention they wouldn't have the huge
wakandan army in Avengers endgame it
would be very very different if T'Challa
was star-lord and last but not least
something that I'm really looking
forward to that is confirmed is a marvel
what if zombies episode now this one is
going to be truly interesting because
what we have here so far photos and
footage are of Bucky fighting a zombie
Captain America we can see the art of
Captain as a zombie here and we can also
see his shield and it's covered in blood
now it's really hard to tell how this
exact scenario with Captain America
becoming a zombie would come to be in
the MCU because remember
this is all based off of little things
that have already happened in the MCU
now Marvel did do a Marvel Zombies comic
back in 2005 it was a limited 5 issue
series now the series was set in a
different Universal wasn't set in the
main universe but what ends up happening
in the story is that an alien comes to
earth and ends up affecting some of the
Avengers the x-men and the Fantastic
Four and basically all of the
superheroes that exist in this universe
and just like any zombie movie that
you've ever seen they get infected by
blood so bites cuts etc so this could be
the story that Marvel what-if is going
to explore but they would have to figure
out a way to work this into the main
universe perhaps one of the Infinity
stones could have turned captain into a
zombie or perhaps even the tesseract but
that's just something that we're going
to have to wait to find out when Marvel
what if comes to Disney Plus and the
good news is we've just heard that
season 1 is basically complete since
it's an animated show most of the work
had been able to continue during kovat
19 most of the work could be done from
home so season 1 is almost wrapped up so
we should be hearing a lot more
information very soon so let me know how
excited you are about Marvel Studios is
what if and out of all these scenarios
that we talked about today which one are
you most excited for be sure to let me
know in the comments down below also
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything related to the MCU for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof